rb is there a success story from stage
32 that you're really proud of and
actually get a little emotional over
there's a well there's a few that i get
very emotional over
one of them um we've had a lot of
sort of single success stories and what
i mean by that is when we have them
every day really
um you know a screenwriter who
was in his mid 50s who you know had
flown close to the sun over a 30-year
uh i don't want to call it a career
because he didn't have one really but a
30-year attempt at a career
had a couple things get optioned a few
things get sold and we never made
and finally got to a point where he was
ready to give up the ghost
and he decided to pitch through through
the stage 32 happy writers
one more time to a manager at benders
bank because he really really believed
in this one script
excuse me and the long story short of it
is that
within a week he had been flown to la
for a meeting
this manager daniel vanga bendersmink
had read
two more pieces of his work and one of
them was a television
um a television pilot that he had
written years ago
and daniel said to him what do you want
to do do you want to write features or
do you want to be in tv and he said well
25 years ago i wanted to be in a
writer's room that was my dream
and he said well why don't you want that
now and he said well because i'm 55
years old and he said
i don't care he said go home and pack
your bags and within a week he had him
on blacklist on abc
so that was a really really cool story
on a much bigger scale
we have a filmmaker his name is david
roundtree um
he is just a great great you know great
guy
and also a guy that uses social media
all the time to vet people
and to you know look for talent he used
he had two films in theaters over the
last six months one was called 108
stitches and another one was called cut
cut just premiered on hollywood
boulevard a couple weeks ago
sold out the whole week um we were it
was the first film that stage 32
exclusively distributed online so we
were really proud of that
and he used for cut i mean for 108
stitches he used 22 stage 32 members
and for cut he used um
34 and the really the cool thing is that
some of the people that he found on
stage 32
were incredibly accomplished the sound
editor
has worked on 170 studio films including
all the pirates of the caribbean movies
and so on and so forth
she was his sound editor he found her on
stage 32 she was a sound editor on both
movies
you know these stories we hear them all
the time you know we just had a composer
in florida who's scoring a movie for a
guy in india one of the very actually
one of the very first
success stories we had was a a composer
story as well it was a filmmaker in la
who had exhausted all his contacts in la
they just weren't getting his film it
was this dark
noir kind of film and he basically
put together a couple of clips and said
put it out in
onto the stage 32 lounge and said i am
willing i'm at
which end i'm willing to have people the
next 10 people that contact me are gonna
have a shot at scoring
these scenes okay and he ended up hiring
a composer from denmark just kept
sending the files over to the
they got on to you know they got on to
chat they talked they you know the video
conference
and this guy got to score his first
hollywood movie
so that gentleman david had a profile
on stage 32 and so he would put that
he's
uh a director composer what he was the
director yeah director okay
yeah anna right he co-wrote one of the
two movies co-wrote cut as well
yeah and so when you said post on the
stage 32 lounge and we did create an
account so i did see
kind of how how it works a little bit
and karma points and all that we'll go
into that later but
so he then put out a call to action or
how does that work if i want to put out
a call
he well there's two different ways we
have a job section
and in the job section you could put up
your project and your needs your cast
and crew needs okay
he went in there and he said i'm looking
for the following actors these types
okay okay um i'm looking for uh i think
he had his cinematographer from the
first film
but i'm looking for this crew you know
people to film the fill these roles
and then other stage 32 members can go
in there
and apply for those roles and again this
is why it's very very important that you
have a completed profile at this point
because now david will go
and look at your resume you know through
the site
um your clips you know everything and
then he can contact you and say
let's you know let's talk about it or
you're not i don't feel like you're
right for it or or whatever
um that's pretty much how he did it with
both movies
and that's how a lot of people on the
site do it you know we have
hundreds of jobs posted every day and
uh you know hundreds of projects that
are live and active at any given moment
and it's free right for the poster and
the completely free
inquiry person okay
you